vem falar de algo que não temos sido a
vossa atenção sobre isso vem dizer vocês
são eventualmente a última esperança
para mudarmos o atual estado de coisas
não pode aqui um bom jornalismo
o melhor que podemos fazer para salvá lo
não é fácil definir o que seja isso bons
noite contudo fácil e extreme de acordo
com o mau jornalismo provoque dós visões
distorcidas e enviesadas de realidade
com o mau jornalismo ficamos
incapacitados de formular juízos sessões
da realidade sejam bem fundamentadas onu
ismael setrerj é trazer para a praça
pública as questões as decisões
os dossiês que escolher todos os players
qualquer tipo de lei tenta evitar que
quer fazer pra passa porque quer manter
escondido é graças ao bom jornalismo que
nós podemos fazer uma ideia mais perto e
mais certa do que é a realidade
mas será que nós podemos fazer alguma
coisa a favor do bom jornalismo
será que ainda hoje no tempo da internet
da uel das redes sociais jornalismo os
media tradicionais têm algum peso têm
alguma importância
creio que aqui nesta sala a maior parte
rocha bastante mais novos do que eu
disse que não
graças à internet às redes sociais e aos
meios aos vossos conhecimentos
específicos podem tomar consciência do
mar conhecimento e saber aqui o que
realmente nos interessa eu vos interessa
essa questão é que é verdade nós na
internet graças às nossas capacidades de
procurarmos podemos com facilidade
aumentar a nossa confiança de que o que
nos interessa contudo é são ainda os
media tradicionais que pela velocidade
de informação junto pela forma como uma
herarquias visão são els constroem para
nós uma seção da realidade que é
praticada pela nossa comunidade
inclusive porque os que não frequentam
este militar adicionais
então pronto
um bom jornalismo será muito pouco ou
nada importante para a sociedade que
estamos a viver hoje e pro futuro
queremos construir
não é suposto nessas conferências
responderem identificam como perguntar
pantanal
eu por mim acho que sim acho que sim mas
antes disso quero lembrar um pouco mais
sobre esse assunto quero convidar em
como fazer uma curta viagem daqui até
madri
no princípio dos anos 90 o la república
eo país tinha acabado de comprar parte
do capital social do jornal público de
hoje a direção eu fazia parte
lembro de ter perguntado é zé luis
cebrián o diretor do el país desde o
início como explicar vá
qual é o país naquelas condições
específicas de espanha fosse tivesse
feito sempre um jornalismo exemplar de
qualidade entender
lembro que eu respondeu
tivemos só tivemos muita sorte fizemos
desde o princípio um simbolismo espanha
e os espanhóis precisavam se tiver um
surto de sorte em dinheiro o nosso
investidor desde o primeiro quer ser
realmente independente quer preservar a
sua independência editorial esquece que
os leitores tenham confiança em ti tu
tens que dar né ganhar né
o museu foi um dos muitos anos suportou
o bom dia noite e era muito simples os
leitores pagava para os anunciantes
pagam fortunas espaço de publicidade que
comprava
cursos as relações tinham
disponibilidades financeiras não
capacitar pessoas equipes que eram
capazes de gastar dias anos antes talvez
não semanas para investigar um assunto
para não se contentarem com versão
oficial deu pra ele ir mais longe para
porém na agenda e na praça pública
assuntos mas ninguém queria vir na praça
pública nas notícias
esse mundo acabou respondeu acabou em
portugal poucas são muito poucas são as
empresas na lista questão do lucro
hoje estamos numa situação em que
fundamentalmente por causa de coisas
boas e interessantes nomeadamente por
causa da internet pela expansão explosão
das redes sociais
esta ideia de que a informação nos paga
a informação sem ser necessário pagar
por tudo isto e pela explosão do
contrato canais de informação que
existem hoje no mundo é publicidade não
paga às redacções os leitores não querem
pagar informação ninguém quer pagar
a informação é que chova que tem
gratidão
nesta situação o que aconteceu foi que
possivelmente ficarão cada vez mais
pequenas
cada vez mais e permanentemente
reduzidas jovens estagiários pouco surge
das citações dos fatos da história de
tenistas e com relações tão pequena
mesmo com os motoristas que querem fazer
bom jornalismo é muito fácil abrir a
janela escancarar a porta aos noivos no
sensacionalista que não perde tempo é
investigar os factos ou a pôr em causa a
versão dos acontecimentos que é vendida
por todo tipo e gênero do porta voz
estamos portanto uma situação bastante
complexa eu diria mesmo que esta crise o
investimento nas relações salvo honrosas
exceções é seguramente um dos problemas
graves das nossas democracias
contemporâneas
então nós podemos fazer nós que até nem
200 anos muitos media tradicionais
3 fazer alguma coisa
primeiro não comigo fazer uma pequena
viagem no tempo
no jantar dos anos 90 uma leitora de
shows que o povo tinha maltratado uma
informação que é punha em causa a gestão
camarária de uma nova câmera claro
estávamos em pré-campanha eleitoral para
as autárquicas e essa leitura uma parte
interessada
o museu que então era provedor do leitor
do público de todas as onze bastante
crítica
o editor que tinha permitido que tal
notícia fosse evitado passar algum tempo
esse eleitor deixou uma forma bastante
mais impressionantes imagens em
melbourne
o comentador político de um sinal da
importância da tela graça deixou o seu
carro deste ano publicou um extenso
documento em casa faria as tropelias que
os editores da tela grave vindo a fazer
nos outros meses para esconder e omitir
notícias que eram os policiais aos seus
investidores e aos seus detidos em geral
são que compravam a publicidade a chance
antes peter deixou muito claro que eu
era absolutamente insuportável continuar
a viver e trabalhar no final cujos
leitores se queixavam dizendo que já não
na que o papel original esquecido seu
mas que sentimento também um estudo
conduzido nos estados unidos por arthur
santana mostrava que 98% 98% dos
jornalistas americanos dos jornais
diários de âmbito nacional e costa esta
costa r 90 e 800 reconheciam que o leão
às críticas que lhe eram feitas cerca de
um pouco mais de um terço da um pouco
mais três quartos dos nudistas expandiu
e sequer dizendo que sua visão do que
era o valor notícia tenha mudado pelo
facto de lerem os comentários aqui o teu
publicado
portanto nós nós o público
nós temos mesmo que as redações digam
nada do ofício deus que os seus
telespectadores ouvintes espectadores
nada entendem do que é ser jornalista
tem em conta
mudam mudam o seu modo de fazer é a
notícia de publicar mudam a sua agenda
na medida em que são criticados
não esqueçam os finalistas pouco mais
tem além do seu próprio nome e ver o seu
próprio nome posto em causa na praça
pública é algo que dói
portanto é minha mensagem é simples
podemos fazer mas cartas telefonemas
protege contra o mau jornalismo é de
certeza um modo de lutarmos pelos bons
no mesmo de nos olharmos aos jornalistas
e puxamos isso tem impacto garante
portanto dance ao trabalho serem
críticos realmente reggina em
criticamente aquilo que é de alguma
forma o player
e ó sem dúvida tudo isto exige tempo a
escrever cartas para diretor de
informação para os dois leitores é certa
existe trabalho mas como está em jogo é
muito muito importante eu acho vale a
pena
não acham obrigado